hales up guys my name is Asha no and
welcome to the very first release of the
Sparky engine so this video we're
basically just going to talk about it
exactly everything that's going into
this release I'm very excited this is
the first release of this barking engine
it's still incredibly early in
development but it's come up to a point
where i can actually kind of release it
and since I've been kind of managing it
on the version of control system rather
than get as well this kind of more or
less signifies me actually pushing the
code to get than an actual kind of like
public release so to speak but anyway
I'm still calling it a release I'm going
to do one of these every month I'm gonna
try and do one of these every month
every if not every two months but this
is the March 2016 release we're just
going to go ahead and look through the
release notes and I'm going to kind of
commentate them and just just discuss
them a little bit i'm going to talk a
bit a bit more about everything else
that that's kind of going to happen with
the future as well so right now i'm
literally uploading the code to github
now it's pretty big and i live in
australia so my upload speed is well not
right so because of that it's just going
to take too long and I I mean ideally I
would have done this video after it was
already on github but not I don't have
time unfortunately to wait for this to
happen but it is uploading right now by
the time you actually see this it will
already be up on github because I
doesn't want to upload this before I
upload the video so if you if you do
head on head on over to github.com for /
the train 04 / Sparky link will be in
the description you should see all the
code for the sparking engine all the up
to date code everything that i have
written up to this point in time will be
here okay the first thing you're going
to want to do is look at these release
knives well that won't work we're
actually going to go through them in
this video's so you can probably watch
the video instead but there will be in a
folder in a folder called documents or
docs and then release notes in the main
kind of thing here but yeah the main
thing is that i want to say with this
release and the major new thing that i'm
kind of opening up is pull requests
right I've up up up to this point in
time I haven't actually accepted a
single
pull request but from now on as soon as
this code goes live I will be accepting
pull requests and I really want you guys
to help me write this engine because
it's obviously a massive task to write a
game engine and there's no way I can do
it by myself especially when you when
you take into consideration all the
little all the little bugs and little
tweaks everywhere that need need work on
as well as like other platforms and all
of this kind of stuff there's just so
many things that need to get added so
little time certainly certainly in my
life there's very little time but not
only that but there's just like one
person can all write a game engine right
so I really want to open this up to be
more of a community thing so if you do
want to contribute to Sparky I'm going
to actually make a video probably
sometime next week that will cover the
details of contributing to Sparky and
how you can do that but if you can if
you can be bothered working that out
yourself you literally can just open you
pull requests with things that you've
you think of fixes or improvements or
new features whatever and I'll look
through them I'll probably comment on
them if you like make a mistake or if I
don't agree with it or something i'll
definitely like comment on them and
we'll we'll have some kind of discussion
as well probably close all these ones
they're incredibly old something's
actually aren't too bad like if everyone
but a lot of them are from last year so
i really do need to kind of close them
but that's that's the big thing right I
really want this to be a community thing
we need right this engine together and
i'll definitely be taking a look at pull
requests and accepting your code ok cool
so that's kind of step 1 the first thing
that i wanted to talk about there's also
going to be a release on github as well
if you go into releases and download it
you should be able to run the engine on
Windows or run I guess a little bit the
binaries for the engine this will this
will include sandbox as well so you
should be able to run that but that's
another thing that will happen as soon
as I and so does this thing uploads you
can see it's going to take forever um
but that's that's the idea ok so that's
the big thing now that's out of the way
we can talk about stuff like we can talk
about stuff like the actual release
notes and I can kind of give you guys a
tour of what's new so I'm just going to
go through this list pretty quickly and
and see what see what's new so the major
new features are basically the sparking
our supports physically based rendering
at the beginning so
the previous get commit we basically
just had a very basic 3d renderer we
didn't have really much in there we
definitely didn't have any kind of
physically based rendering i believe the
lighting model was just kind of your
standard diffuse kind of i forgotten the
exact term for it but it's just kind of
normal based lighting like that's pretty
much all we had in there it's very very
basic we had very primitive kind of 3d
rendering so now we have a have a proper
3d render a proper 3d forward renderer
and in fact one that supports physically
based like shading and all that stuff
physically based rendering and all that
stuff right we also support both OpenGL
and DirectX so before we we only support
a rep in jail and the the all of the
graphics all of the engine really was
written in a way to only support OpenGL
so now it's basically most of the code
is API independent which is good which
means that if I want to add another if
we want to add another rendering
rendering API such as Vulcan or maybe
metal or anything else really that's
going to be a lot easier now because
it's really as simple as just hooking
everything up with a new API and that's
it like rotten low most of the engine is
written in an API independent way and
also in a platform-independent way as
well we only support windows right now
but when we do support want platforms
again that will be easy but that's
besides the point right api independent
so now we now we can support up in jail
and DirectX 11 direct3d 11 and we do
support that and the sandbox will run on
both of these which is fantastic with
physically based rendering as well which
is great Sparky now has a custom 3d
model format it's a dot SPM file right
looks like that so this is a model this
is a sparking model file if you see
these around the way that you build them
is you use your 3d program of your 3d
modeling application of choice whether
that be blender or autodesk maya or
autodesk 3d studio max right anything
from those tools you can export
something called an FBX file which is an
Autodesk kind of format it's kind of an
open format though like all of the API
is is up there on the internet that you
can just you can just use it you don't
need like a license for it or anything
you just need to state that you're using
it that's it so that's you can easily
integrate that into
I don't know anything that you're using
but an F like FBX is a very good
intermediate model format for 3d models
because it's very complete it supports
pretty much everything that's why I
chose to you know do this specifically
suppose anything it's supposed anything
really from like you know like blending
like morph targets and stuff and like
skeletal animation bones and just
everything really that you could imagine
any kind of vertex attributes it's very
very powerful it supports this whole
node-based kind of hierarchy and it's
just a very complete model for man that
has everything you could possibly want
so it's perfect to choose for this so
what you do is you use the build tool
you basically feed into the build tool
an FBX file and it will output an spm
file for you and so far I haven't made
anything that makes a crash yet you will
need to make sure that the FBX file has
certain vertex attributes so basically
apart from the regular ones which is
like position you vs and normals you'll
also need to make sure that any 3d model
you that you export has tangents and by
normals okay because they're required
for physically based rendering or well
more specifically they required for
normal mapping right so and spm like the
the build tool will enforce that like it
will tell you if you don't have them
like they're required so that that's
really the only thing though but you
should be able to feed at any FBX model
multiple measures and stuff don't work
yet SPM is actually really really
primitive I wrote this in a single day
and like more of the in fact narrowing
that down i wrote this in about four
hours this whole SPM file format so it's
very very young right and it doesn't
support much at all and I'll definitely
work on that probably sometime in the
future but for now it's actually not bad
we've got cost to memory allocation
control what I mean by that is I've
overloaded the new and delete operators
and I'm forwarding them into an
alligator class so that we can track
allocations and in the future we can
control where the memory gets allocated
from okay so right now is just tracking
memory statistics but in the future it
will also probably control like you know
the actual allocation and then finally
I've converted all the main
six mouths to be ro major so it used to
be called a major opengl style but now
throw a major which is kind of more
direct exile and we will probably see
some performance improvements from that
change when i actually properly like
when I actually start optimizing the
mass library which isn't yet okay cool
so the full list when I kind of got to
just gloss through this really quickly
so OpenGL direct access the a profession
higher ended support multiple rendering
api's freetype GL yeah so that's another
thing free type GL which is a project
which is actually on github it's an open
source project that basically takes the
rasterized pixels from free type and
actually formats them properly into an
open GL texture so it actually it
actually packs like all of the
individual glyphs into a texture atlas
or a sprite shape whatever you want to
call it and so that that's what we use
free time shelf or so before freetype GL
at least the project that's on github
used to actually just make the open GL
texture I've changed it so that it
actually gives us access to an array of
pixels and then I've moved it so that
instead of free type GL generating
OpenGL textures we actually feed that
pit feed those pixels into Sparky's
texture classes and their API
independent so basically I've made free
type GL work with drag acts and and
OpenGL and anything really so I've kind
of reef that really changed this to just
really just provide me with a packed
texture in the form of a bunch of pixels
and that's it a few bugs that I fixed
here sometimes the close button like the
red X close button didn't actually close
the window for some reason so I've fixed
that bug this was there just go mouse
releasing so sometimes like you would if
you click on the window and then you
kind of drag the mouse out of the window
and then you release the mouse the
release of them wouldn't get registered
because the mouse wasn't getting kind of
captured when you clicked so that would
lead to like the debug menu when you
were scrolling sorry when you is you
when you were using the slider for
example you click drag up and then
you'll release the mouse to stop but
then when you kind of drag the mouse
into the window even though your mouse
button wasn't pressed it was still kind
of the slider would still follow the
mouse because it was it thought it was
still clicked because there was no
release event so fix that bug window
focused and resize events so now you can
actually in the event system you can
actually see if a window loses or gains
focus and whether on the window resizes
and I'm propagating those resize events
to the renderer so that they know that
the viewport size has changed yeah PBR
is in normal mapping for PBR is in so
the PBR models that I'm using our disney
diffuse and ggx they're slightly
modified I've slightly changed them but
they're basically based on frostbites
physically based rendering paper which
is about 120 pages it's very good it's
on the internet if you can find it i'm
going to i will eventually make a video
on physically based rendering and when i
do that i'm going to cover everything in
detail because i know a lot of people
are interested in is i just don't have
time right now but don't worry that'll
be like an hour or two video probably
specifically on the topic image based
lighting for PBR as well so basically
this is like environment kind of
lighting week and where the lighting
depends on an image which is kind of
your cube map your environment that's
extremely important for PBR because
you're lighting obviously should be
based on your surroundings def textures
best shadow rendering this is again
obsolete so not even worth mentioning
deferred rendering like the code for
this is technically in the engine but
it's really bad and it doesn't work so
I'm just I've added like these this is
in the change logo or the release notes
because the code is physically there
like there's a class that's like a
deferred rendering there's deferred
around or adult page and I'll CBP but
they don't actually work okay they did
at one point but anyway so yeah cost a
model file format for meshes the bill
tool for FPS p.m. conversion PBR
material so now there's material and PBR
material which is just PBR material just
gives you access to methods such as set
set environment map and set gloss maps
at like normal map set set diffuse map
or whatever cell
no map and set specular map we'll all
that kind of stuff right so you can set
the textures instead of having to set
the uniforms and other uniform names and
all that it's just really for
convenience I think and it all it
automatically sets the pre-integrated FG
texture as well which is a topic for
another video cubemate oh so yeah with
engine now supports texture cubes of
course which is important for image been
sliding material render flags so you can
tell materials how you want them to
render so for example should the render
render this with the dev testing on or
off should the renderer how should the
renderer blend but right now it
literally just supports def testing
which was important for the skybox to
work but it basically will include start
like blend rights uniform struct
alignment so like the light the light
struct for example is 16 by the line it
has to be I mean it doesn't really like
have to be but it should be that most of
these most of these data structures
should actually be 16 byte aligned also
right in fact like structs for example
in structs in in hlsl actually do have
to literally have padding in them to
ensure that certain members are like
aligned up to the size of the maximum
member so to speak which is about 16
bytes so for example if you have a vac
three and then avec for you can't do
that you have to have a vac three then
like a float of padding and then a back
for anyway topic for another video
probably in terms of in-depth render of
class so yes you have a render of class
so that you can control stuff that isn't
like specific to say the batch render or
the forward renderer but stuff that is
actually rendering API more like so like
death testing blend modes free image is
now part of the solution it used to just
be an external library now it's actually
been compiled so that we get access to
free rent utilities because we didn't
before and that's also compiling as a
static elaborate II don't need the dll
okay so created renderer API independent
blend modes and buffer types what does
that mean yeah so basically there are
just like sparky has its own deck
laureate like its own definitions for
like blend modes and buffer types so you
can instead of having to use like you
know GL
horse alpha there is actually just like
a source alpha kind of I think that
later gets translated to the API
depended on one what it actually gets
used with the API buffle outs now over
gelled z episode buffle outs of support
directx now rewrote the entire class
Chad class has changed a lot I'd
encourage you guys to look at that shade
like how shaders work and Sparky is an
entire topic for a massive video because
obviously like they're smart in the
sense that like when you create a shader
and Sparky from like a source file it
like the shadow class knows like all the
uniforms that's in it it know it you can
give the shader just a buffer like a
byte buffer filled with data for the
uniforms and it will just set them
whether or not it would be for DirectX
OpenGL so it's pretty amazing and you
can also ask the shader hey shader what
uniforms do you have and it will
actually tell you so it's it's really
cool and it's it's all its massive so
it's I'm not going to talk about it now
for drained right now uses system
uniforms this is so complicated I just
want to tell you guys this this stuff is
just like there is so much stuff going
on here that it's just it's actually I'm
actually feeling a bit bad because
there's no way I can explain all of this
right now or maybe possibly ever so it's
it's just this so much to learn from
this code I'd encourage you guys just
really just read it like a book might be
difficult at times but go for anyway so
if you can work out or some of these
things are so boolean studio menu so the
dev up menu I suppose boolean so you can
be like you can add a bullet into it and
then you can toggle it by the debug menu
are there's a first-person camera custom
allocated class as I said which was up
here as well customer memory allocation
controls we can track memory usage as
well as later actually allocate stuff
there's SP new NSB delete macros memory
management so basically they will SP new
for example adds automatically adds the
file and the line that the allocation
came from so you can track allocations
that way if you really want to there is
no actual memory metrics kind of class
so we don't actually the data doesn't go
anywhere but it's there
so like it's a good idea to sign
introducing this now so that later they
won't have to be a massive like
find/replace new to a spin you or
something so it's yeah again this stuff
is just a topic from the video dynamic
shadowy learning for opengl don't
actually know if it still works but it
will did at one point the debugger
andrew doesn't work with that will
basically just you know display like
lines and stuff and there's a lot of
stuff to this is fantastic so this stuff
all just failed because can't get half
as a file size limit of 100 Meg I don't
know what I'm going to do so FP FP SDK
and reimage don't live I guess you guys
will just have to get that code
elsewhere anyway um that's fantastic
yeah the huge yeah the FBX SDK things
are massive anyway um what else we have
here are there are integer type deaths
now so like instead of having to use
short char long because there might be
compiled dependent you now have in 1816
in 32 etc so in a to the same as a bite
or rather you in 28 would be the same as
a bite in 32 would be the same as an int
usually and like you know u int32 would
be the same as you end which is the same
as unsigned int anyway there are a few
type tabs just for convenience and to
make sure the where we are supporting
multiple platforms while compilers yeah
the sandbox project has a lot of
resources like PBR assets and stuff
fixed a bunch of compiler warnings here
and there Visual Studio filters should
be good now as well and China graph is
gone and known issues I'm sure there are
a lot i actually did not keep track of
them i open an issue on github if you
find any issues and i'll try and fix
them or someone else can fix them by a
pull request ok guys so that's pretty
much the end of the change logs of all
the release notes that's what's changed
i'm going to probably start putting up
videos on how you guys can make games
with this i don't know if it's really
that ready yet i don't think i want to
change the api too much the back end
will certainly change but the api is
actually i think pretty stable i'm
pretty happy with it so i may start
making videos on how to make games with
Sparky let me know if you guys are
interested in that
also what should we do for the April
release right that is my question to you
guys should we should we keep working on
3d stuff right I mean there's a lot to
do like for example like shadow
rendering isn't even in yet like
properly we're still missing poster
facts like post-processing affects our
stuff like bloom and like we're missing
HDR buffers so that we can do like
proper exposure proper camera exposure
stuff as well as like adaptive exposure
and automatic exposure like that all
that all that stuff is missing what else
you know depth feel blur like motion
blur there's so many effects that we
could do with post effects right screen
space effects of course like screen
space ambient occlusion screen space
reflections so much stuff could be done
pretty easily if only we had post
effects so and they are technically in
there like as a post-effective class but
of course doesn't work with the current
API should we start working on tools
such as the level editor yeah I'd love
to make a level editor for this number
and before we do that we need a
civilization format ah so much work man
so much work I wish I could spend more
time working on Sparky but fortunate con
so that's why I'm handing it off to you
guys I'm going to obviously still keep
working on it as much as possible but
like I actually can't do this without
you guys so I really want your help I'll
probably put out a video on how you can
start contributing to Sparky but it
would be awesome if we could form some
kind of team like if there are people
out there who are fairly competent with
C++ and graphics programming and you
guys want to step up and be like quote
unquote moderators of Sparky as in like
you'll be like slightly you'll have
slightly more responsibility than just
random people with pull requests then I
would love for some people to do that
like obviously you'd have to know what
you're talking about so you'd have to
have some experience and you'd have to
have the time to spend on Sparky as well
but if there are people out there who
actually want to work on this project
then please let me know because I need
some people to help me out with this
thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed
please hit the like button
and leave your leave your thoughts in
the comments below if you want to
support Sparky and you can't help
actually write the code then if you head
on over to patreon.com for such the
cherno you can pledge any amount like a
dollar is fine per month that's fine if
you guys all pledged a dollar then I'm
gonna be a lot happier and I'm going to
be able to spend a lot more time on
Sparky anyway thanks for watching guys
I'll see you next time goodbye